well thanks so much for coming down to
my house guys congratulations on going
full time in property you guys are
really killing it you're making big
moves you've quit your jobs you've made
like 12 grand last month in property
you've bought houses you've flipped
houses so i just thought really it'd be
good for me to get like some inside
information so the listeners can copy
exactly what you've done and emulate it
so how did you get started and what was
your first deal
so me personally i've ran a marketing
company for last six seven years but
always had a passion for property um so
when the pandemic here i decided to
start looking into it bought my first
little buy to let which is just a small
little flat up in newcastle put that as
a
rental property
and then i decided to go bigger buy a
big detached house but moved in for two
or three months got really bored so
looked into renting that out
and then i started looking to
projects so i bought like a deceased
estate um and then wanted to renovate it
had quite a lot of connections with
builders and construction workers up
there and then i sort of come in contact
with yourself and realize that you can
rent it room by room and different style
strategies so that's all how it all came
about really nice so you were kind of
already you know got into property you
bought your first one or two houses and
then how did you come across how did you
come out of our training and stuff on
youtube or yeah i literally got a link
sent of amelia's winners on a wednesday
no uh and i sent it out to mel i was
like we need to watch this yeah and then
back in december there was a crash
course in leeds and just booked myself
on it well done what about yourself so i
worked for lewis in his marketing
company as his head of operation so me i
was quite blank with property i didn't
really
have any idea on property as i just kind
of saved and bought the first house
and used my deposit so lewis then came
back from your crash course and he said
you've got one or two options kind of
i'm going to go full time property you
can the options to come with me
or you have got a job still secure here
and i said let's just take the risk
let's go let's go on the property so you
worked for lewis
yeah and then lewis was like i'm going
full time into property now do you want
to be involved or do you just want the
job so now
you quit that job yes
you lost an employee dude
wow
so that's crazy and interesting though
because you saw the video where i helped
amelia did that kind of resonate sort of
seeing boss helps employee kind of thing
running a marketing company i always
felt like i wanted to pull other people
up um so when i came into property i
really saw a way of doing that that's so
good bro respect for that because
there's so many bosses that try and keep
money making secrets and business
principles from their staff and the
whole system you've heard me say this a
million times the whole system is
created for people to be poor
because the banks and the schools the
government and the employers
we're responsible the employers just
want their employees to just be good
have their pension
work hard monkey do this
but the thing is it's so important to
get the best out in people like kerry
for instance the lady that's filming
this she's financially free so she works
now from a position of choice but
because she's working from a position of
choice she's actually working probably
better than
she would be if she was having to do it
so mad respect for that so when did you
guys go full time in property then when
did that happen so it was about a month
and a half ago we just had a full-time
property and what happened in the last
month and a half since she went full
time we just 10xed it we just really
really wanted to
go as fast as possible i was fortunate
enough from the few houses i had once i
started your training i managed to
systemize that to be kind financially
free
but i wanted to put myself in a position
where i needed to get the next deal and
make more money um so
yeah we just sort of learned from what
you taught us really on selling deals i
want to get some rent to essays and we
also have a real big goal to
go abroad so we want to get properties
abroad in europe you know i love the sun
lived in australia for a couple of years
so that's what gave us the motivation
really just to keep going nice and now
you've got rent to rent that you're
going to secure in where portugal
yeah on friday we'll have a look at them
this friday and you just secured a rent
to rent deal today yeah so where's the
big money i know rent defense is quite a
new addition to your strategy you've
you've got your brr buy to let where's
the bulk of the money coming from so
we have a
potential deal about to go through which
is like uh
on land so the goal is to
essay that deal with a couple of lodges
because it's right next to a caravan
park and then potentially get plan and
permission on the land and then either
sell the land off or build on that land
as well
that's big money that's slow money that
takes forever what was the cash flow how
much did you make last month
cash flow last month so from my personal
deals i've got about 3 000 a month
coming in from my personal deals right
that's that's yours the houses that you
bought you've systemized them that's
your financial freedom part yeah okay
and then obviously we sold
four deals last week together together
um and from that we generated fourteen
and a half thousand yeah ourselves oh
that's where it's coming from it's just
started towards london last week was
that you were going to go up the course
and we were like i said louis i feel
like you need to come back and for some
reason he was i think i need to knock
out the course this week come back and
that week we made 40 and a half rounds
wow
so
the interesting thing is you'd already
got some property experience because you
bought a house you know
the training obviously helped you
systemize and turn into hmos and stuff
like that but the interesting thing is
just last month you guys together as a
team
brought in 14 and a half grand and
that's from what packaging and selling
deals
so tell me what does it mean to package
and sell a deal we go out we look for
the houses and things we then obviously
package do all our due diligence we
package it together and we kind of send
out our investors on our investors list
and obviously when they send back to us
we kind of sell out the deal and we send
them across
deal packaging a year ago no i hadn't
even heard of it two months ago
that's crazy what about you like
the concept of because i know you guys
joined the academy like what like three
four months ago me just after deal
selling course mel the start of march
what made you make that decision you're
obviously a marketer you're already a
property investor what made you make the
decision to invest so heavily into your
education honestly the network is
incredible coming from what we do is the
exact same thing i had a few coaches
that you know very successful in my
previous industry i just realized by
coming to your crash course coming to
the first deal sourcing event if you can
get in with the guys and girls that are
doing what you want to do yeah you're
going to be able to progress way faster
and then when we came back from the deal
71 i booked me and mel on as many
networking events as possible and we
went and met people in birmingham and
people in newcastle all across the
northeast and that's what made the
biggest difference and once start people
started seeing us do well on our social
media yeah you know it gave a lot of
people belief and it all just came from
really the network of the academy to be
honest wow and that's the thing you can
either go fast alone or far together
you know what have you found the
experience of the academy so far it's
been amazing like obviously i didn't
know anything about property until i
kind of took the sides i've been to
doing it with louise a month and a half
ago yeah and now i feel like i can't
believe i've just made four and a half
grand in a week i'm just like what
so i thought it's definitely who you
know not what you know about it's what
you know until you know as well but
because of the networks we've made in
the academy we would never have been
able to get where we are without it yeah
that's so good and that's what we like
to do we like to find people um not
always but sometimes that are already
having a bit of success yeah like you
were having a bit of success and they're
already going to be successful on their
own but what we can do is we can make it
happen faster and bigger and have fun
doing it so you know it's just great to
see how fast and i said to you as well
about coming on this show you know we'll
have you again you know in maybe six
twelve months and do a part two because
i've no doubt you're gonna take over the
world talk to me um about lewis your bio
refurbished refinance deal
run the figures on it and explain you
know the process of how that happened so
i built quite a lot of connections with
people in the auction teams up in the
northeast a couple of the guys used to
work for my company and when they
realized i was in property they started
offering me a lot of
deals uh and this deal came up it failed
at the auction and there's like there's
a chance for a post uh auction agreement
nice so i secured it really cheap i had
one day to do it like i turned up on the
day and then the auction was going the
next day um and we got a really really
good price 71 000 pounds we secured it
for it only took me about five thousand
pounds in refurb costs so i've done
quite a little quite a lot of the stuff
myself um i then turned it into like a
four bed hmo
i rented out to three of my ex-employees
um which was handy uh and then we done a
refinance on it and it managed to pull
out it cost me about 30 grand all in to
with the deposit and actually refurb i
managed to put 33 000 pounds from that
deal wow and now it's generating 1400 a
month that's the most amazing deal ever
yeah so and where is that that's in
newcastle it's just like 10 minutes out
of the season so visit that house
so what you bought it for 75 71 71
you spent five grand turning into a hmo
yeah you then got it valued at 100 15
115 pulled out all your money and some
extra money 100 tax free yeah
and then rent it out as a hmo
and now you're finding deals obviously
not every deal is as good as that that
deal and you posted that deal on tick
tock and it had a million views yeah it
did blow up it blew up that was a shock
to be honest because we have a girl that
does our social media for us um and a
lot of time you just don't get time to
see it cause you're just busy getting
things done and mel's the superstar when
it comes to all the organization i'm
sort of on the ground go to the viewing
spend time with the builders but mel
puts everything in place and sort of
tells me where i can go and what i can't
what did you think of the negative
comments that you had on that video
because i know there was there was like
you know yeah what i just like if i've
been funny like yeah it was just funny
isn't it um yeah i've had quite a lot of
negativity from what i've done
previously because we've done direct
sales it's like door-to-door sales and
event sales commission only it's quite a
lot of stigma behind that anyway so
coming into this it was sort of just a
different form of negative it is
different i was very surprised though to
be honest yeah but i suppose it's the uk
and i want i do warn people of this on
the academy i say when you become
financially free you're going to start
having even friends and family might
suddenly not want you to be doing it or
think oh what are you doing be careful
and then and then even when you win
like you guys did then it's like oh
you're everything that's wrong with the
economy
you know you're greedy landlords it's
like you can't win and i think it's
really important to when you're starting
a business just remember that actually
you know what people's opinions don't
really matter it's about what am i doing
is this helping people am i making money
ethically morally what am i doing with
my finances and it's so important to
have people around you like on the
academy who are rooting for you and are
like-minded i think environment is
everything yeah and that's what i love
about the courses as well because they
come around so regularly if you feel
like you're hitting a bit of a lull yeah
you go to a course and bang straight
back up again yeah definitely and you
build that relationship with people on
the academy that it's like going back
and seeing friends again so yeah
so where you mentioned investor list
where do we get this list baby who are
these people connections that we've made
from what networking events but also
kind of when we came to yours like some
other people still do who are authorized
academy as well yeah but also like the
different events we kind of have our own
links that we just kind of give out we
give our information out so amazing
quite a few investors on our list we
could always
do a wall yeah you know i find out that
it's strange because to start with you
don't have any investors yeah and you
have a couple of deals coming through
and then you have loads of investors and
no deals and now with the other way we
get thrown deals all the time wow but
now i haven't got enough investors for
the deals it's always the way you know
one minute you've got too many investors
then you've got too many deals and it's
like a balancing act how do you find
your deals then like where where do you
go you mentioned you got that first one
from auction or post auction after you
didn't sell but generally speaking where
are you picking up your deals that
you're selling so it's a network a lot
of yeah i got quite a good relationship
with a lot of estate agents kind of
getting our faces out there getting
known so we get quite a lot of like
off-market deals and all the things sent
to us we kind of don't just we go out
we're looking for them i was driving
along the road wasn't i was like oh my
god we've got bespoke sauce and he's
looking for like a care home type style
i was like oh my god there's a care home
like as i'm just driving past and you
start to notice a lot more things when
you're driving along and you see
different things like oh can i get a
lease option off them oh can i do this
so and you're in sunderland where are
you guys newcastle
um which is close by which is so good
right now for deals yeah and that's the
thing like even if someone's on the
academy and they're trained or me for
instance i don't need to pay someone to
find me deals i can find my own deals
but i still will pay someone
because because if if you're in
newcastle just driving to newcastle and
back just having somebody that's that's
done the negotiations has been out
that's viewed 20 houses in the rain
that's negotiated like i'm gonna happily
pay three thousand five thousand if the
deal's right um so you know deal
sourcing sometimes people think why
would you pay money to a deal sorcerer
but well because they found you a really
good deal that would have taken you
hours to find yourself to add to what
mel said as well a lot of the deals we
have now is for exactly that people that
don't live quite in newcastle so there's
a few other people in the academy that
throw us deals all the time and they
can't go and view them because it's like
two hours three hours away and they find
all these incredible deals so we're just
on the doorstep yeah and that's sort of
what we've found working really well now
mel's you know done a lot of the
operational side of stuff from hers and
then i'm in the city center i'm just
popping from place to place and doing
all the viewings how do you manage
problems because as as deal sources if
you made 14 grand last month
that will come with problems headaches
agents saying i'm really sorry there's a
higher offer on this and then you have
to break the news to the investor
investors pulling out asking for refunds
it's not as easy as just oh i'll just
sit back and do nothing and make like
you've gotta to make 10 20 30 grand a
month as a deal seller yes it's possible
but it is hard work now don't get me
wrong having a job's hard
but the pressures of being a deal seller
are real
if you're making the kind of money
you're making if you just sell one deal
a month and you're really
and you're really choosy of who you sell
to and
you can literally replace an average
salary like that in a dollar
but to be scaling it like you guys are
doing how do you deal with the problems
yeah so um
it's about having the right team i think
really so like i said mel's so much
better at me with
the contracts with the agreements with
the email and back and forth like
contacting the investors that way and
i'm better when it comes to on the
ground so speaking to the investor over
the phone speaking to your staging over
the phone speaking to the building team
and it just it's just bouncing off each
other really to be honest but there has
been a lot of problems um one morning we
woke up and like three people wanted
deals and we had like three people's
fees to hit the account and it was like
it was a little bit shocking wasn't it
to be honest we had three deals sell in
one day yeah three different sales we
were like oh my god right i've gone from
selling none this week to now three at
the end of the week we were like how do
we handle this well i was like take all
the contracts up send them outreach
investor you were like talking to the
estate interview oh god this is a little
bit it is very stressful but the rewards
after obviously i once sold six deals in
in one afternoon
bang bang bang you know and and and
there isn't
once probably it sounds like a heavy
word but there's like an aftermath
because when you sell a lot of deals
these investors are all like now i want
to see the deal i want to view it i'm
going to do my research i want to be
hand-held i want some support i want
someone to listen to me and and and it
is it can be quite stressful um but at
the same time the best deals that you
find you keep yourself
so it's just the perfect business to do
in property and that's exactly what
happened like it was like a four year
because it all went in the account and
then bang we had to quickly get
everything in order yeah and that was i
suppose the thing that was like the most
important for the because for them
you're the one deal if that makes sense
but for us it's like it was multiple so
it's hard to
keep that balance and for me it's really
important i think to for the customer
service side of things yeah because i
think you've mentioned it a lot one
investor have a good experience with you
they're going to come back and again
again so we really want to do that with
people biggest objection you get from
investors because no one wants to just
give you their money
this will be the investors dream
scenario the investors dream scenario
would be reserve it for me yeah i want
first refusal i'll then go and look at
look at it in my own time and then i'll
pay you as and when maybe even after
completion right however that's not how
we do things how we do things is if
we've gone out and worked really hard on
we've got a deal it's first come first
served baby
is payment
yeah we have to like like what you do we
trained our investors so we had someone
say we're really interested
like well that's okay if you're going to
pay the fee we'll give you all the
information if not it has to go the next
investors
so we kind of train our investors to
know that the deals that when they come
up their goal do you do a 14-day calling
off period
right and then people say oh what
happens if there's a refund well that
might happen but generally speaking no
one's gonna pay you five grand for a
laugh yeah if they're gonna pay you a
full finder's fee up front the only
reason they're gonna ask for a refund is
if the deal was a letdown in which case
there would have been problems anyway
definitely yeah so that makes sense so
and a lot a lot is about training your
investors exactly what i did so if i
have someone that's um you know unsure
about whether they want to buy or not
and they're on the fence i'll just go no
problem call me back in an hour
because i know it'll be gone in an hour
obviously we sent out the email the
email back straight away and was like
right i want to get this deal can you
send one permission like that's fine no
problem like you said pay the finer
speed whatever you say oh can i have
another few hours to think about well
that's fine but it's going to get sent
out before we sent out all the investors
and then we'd sold that deal and he'd
come back saying oh i've spoke my wife
about it i think i want it we're not
unfortunate the deal's gone right if we
have another one come up we will email
out type thing but it's gone at the
moment yeah and then he'll be your next
buyer next time i think he's actually
text us today for that deal
um which is crazy and you have to learn
that yourself though like you can
obviously teach it but you've obviously
already had that experience yeah so
we've made the mistakes the same thing
we trusted investors what we maybe
shouldn't have
and we've learned that lesson you get i
warned you man
tell me about the deal selling
masterclass what's what's that like
incredible incredible i just love the
way that you actually it's more of a do
and i think ricky says it all the time
like he just gets you on the phone and
we're quite comfortable that anyway
because mel's always been on the phone
i've always been face to face with
customers so that's not the problem but
the reason you just make it so
streamlined yeah to go from you've got a
deal a lead i suppose and how you
package that and get that ready to go to
an investor yeah and everyone does it so
differently as well but your training
makes it streamlined the way i see it i
almost see it it's not quite but it
wants it from like a franchise because
we say this is the business this is how
you do it we created this and it took
years and you do this this this this and
then we show you
on the phone sell deals to investors and
once you see it you can't unsee it it's
like right and then you guys after
you've been to the masterclass bang
making crazy money but it's incredible
what you've done what's like what's your
plans then over the next year what are
you hoping to sort of really focus on
well we had a little goal we first
started and transferred over which was
my goal which was i wanted to make my
yearly salary in six months yeah and
then we've just made halfway getting
started in a week
so now he's got a lot of bigger things
the goals and make it massive make
bigger that's amazing and we set a goal
as well every ten thousand pound we make
we're going to go on a little holiday
dude you're going to be on holiday every
week bro 100 that's the goal that is the
goal though it shows what you said
because i think a lot of people they set
10-year business plans yeah and it's too
long you need to take your 10-year
business plan put it into a month
and just smash it yeah because you can
achieve so much
with the right education and the right
action you guys obviously have worked
super hard on what we've done and you
you know deserve every success but i'm
so pleased to hear that you made your
annual salary
she just kept calling me up she just
couldn't believe i was like it's
actually the account i was like yes in
the account
i've never seen that much money wow so
okay so what would you say then in terms
of
yourself now to someone that's just
starting out this brand new
you didn't know anything a few months
ago about property at all lewis
obviously had some experience from his
own buy to let's but from someone brand
new what would you say that if you were
advising them what would be the first
steps to get into property 100 get
educated and definitely network like it
isn't kind of it isn't how fast you do
it's like getting to know people get
yourself surrounded by the right
environment learn the right education
and then it'll all fall follow because
you can't not do it right if you've got
the right education like i couldn't not
sell a deal now that i know how to sell
a deal yes so i can't just jump in it
blind and think oh my god i'm gonna be
able to be a millionaire soon yeah i've
had to have that education be educated
surround myself with the right
environment and that's pushed me to kind
of get where i am 100
that's amazing what louise what's your
strongest reason for do you're very
driven guy worked very very hard
invested a lot in yourself yeah making a
lot of money what was the reason for all
of this honestly family that's the
reason my dad
was a builder by trade bricklayer and he
spent 50 years building houses and he
was i was really fortunate when i was
growing up he bought a barn when i was
three converted it we lived in it for 25
years
absolutely amazing i've sort of grown up
around that so i wanted to do that i've
also seen him work at least 70. yeah so
i wanted to sort of combine the both if
that makes sense and help my mom help my
sister help my dad and also my future
family as well so it's amazing that's
really why i get the the passion from
yeah but also just i want to be on a
beach somewhere am i actually making
money when i'm sleeping rather than
when i'm there every day
yeah well passive income is so real and
property is the best way to make passive
income so incredible
so if people want to get connected with
you guys which they should because i
just want to say not only have you
obviously you've taken a lot from the
academy i know you've had a lot of
business calls mentoring but you've also
given a lot as well you know you've
helped so many people in the academy
your energy and you've joint ventured
and collabs so what's the best way to
get in touch with people watch this and
think man i'd love to work with these
guys what's the best way to do that so
our biggest ways on instagram uh is
platinum property development platinum
property development yeah that's the
instagram page we have an awesome girl
called hillary that does our social
media for us also tick tock which is pl
uh platinum underscore property and
we've actually just set up our own
website we'll be live in a couple of
weeks time as well amazing well i'll
leave all those links in the description
which will be amazing so people can
connect um what's it been like then
working with me over the last few months
how's it been amazing
absolutely amazing like your energy is
just amazing so when you come to the
event you just feel super recharged and
like you want to go and you want to go
you've got that full constant support
like you've got your mentoring calls you
want one night it's just amazing having
that network there yeah and also just
clearing the time as well every monday
night every monday at 8 o'clock i feel
bad if i can't physically get on it and
i'm like samuel's got so much going on
and he's still there on the calls every
monday i think that's massive and also
the team you created around it as well
you know i think it's just makes it
massive well thank you guys so lewis
final words of wisdom
anyone watching this that needs a real
golden nugget
go
just your network is your net worth bang
love it guys thank you for coming down i
really appreciate it guys i hope you
enjoyed watching the video that i'm sure
you can agree what they're doing is
absolutely amazing packaging and selling
deals keeping the best ones full time in
property if you enjoyed this video do me
a favor and hit like if you want to come
and meet myself and the team and get to
actually meet some property investors
then come on down to the property
investors crash course i'll leave a link
in the description also if you want to
see more interviews like this you can
check out a whole playlist right here
and don't forget to subscribe so we'll
see you next time
[Music]
you